you finally played uh 13 sentinels after
god's recommendation last week yep i
beat it in three days
yeah so uh obviously you guys watched
last week where i recommended 13
sentinels these guys so i thought you
know i i didn't know if they would take
my recommendations in the well of
recommendations yeah yeah i was just i
was just like you know i'm just going to
continue playing it i've like i'm like
playing it at a comfortable pace
and then three days after recording joey
texts me and goes i finished 30 seconds
what the [ __ ]
i literally went home that recording
night downloaded it started playing i
played i was like i'll give it a couple
of hours right just like like as god
said i'll give it a couple of hours just
to warm up see if i even get into the
groove
i got into the groove all right
because the three days after that it was
just me waking up having like six
coffees just so i could [ __ ] stay
focused in this game playing it for like
10 to 12 hours straight going to bed
yeah
it is like now now that i have someone
to talk to it about
uh i could without spoiling well we
can't talk about it but we can't talk
about it because like i get like now
someone finally understands that i
actually think 13 incentives 13
sentinels might be
the most insane plot i've ever seen in a
video game i haven't even finished it
yet yeah it is it is by far one of the
craziest like video game stories or just
stories in general i've like sat through
yeah it's f like so god last week made
the comparison of it's like boccarano
mixed with steins gate yeah right as
someone who's finished the game i can
say
he's right on that but only on like a
surface level because it's like it is
like it has elements of bulk runner like
with the robots and it has elements of
steins game which is the time traveling
aspect but then you combine that with
like ghosts in the shell and the matrix
oh god that's and and just imagine all
four of those mashed into one story how
is that cohesive
somehow i don't know how they did it i
don't know how but it is but it is out
of 10 out of 10 like strong nine wow i
haven't finished it yet but like playing
through it now you get to about the
third of the waypoint right and you
think like because i'm going to say
there are there are twists
obviously
there are there are twists in this story
and i remember i remember getting about
the third of the way through i'm just
like i know the twist
i know that's going to happen and then
sure enough what i predicted happened
and then that was just like the twist
that lead into another twist that lead
into that lead it into a [ __ ] bigger
twist like there were moments as i was
playing especially the second half where
you think like you're like all right
this same story has been told from 13
different perspectives right so you're
like so you follow everything you're
like okay i think i know what's going on
and i think i can predict what's about
to happen but there were moments where a
character would say one line and i
literally have to put my controller down
just to be like
i don't believe you just said that
because now
what i thought i knew about this game is
completely out of the window yeah
but it's still but it's not like but it
doesn't come out of left field either i
genuinely want to know
what the writing process is what the
writing process is it's so it's so
insane how many times
you get [ __ ] actual physical whiplash
for like new new plot elements that get
added that seems that make that is like
bat [ __ ] crazy if you explain it out of
context but like in context it makes the
most perfect sense it makes perfect
sense it makes like the [ __ ] fate law
look like disney you know kingdom
kingdom i think i said to god i taste
the god saying it makes the kingdom
heart's law look like sesame street
like kingdom heart fans are going
finally a coherent story i can follow
along with you know like it's it's
it's like i i can't i can't put into
words how actual insane the story is but
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] incredible i
don't know how it works but it just does
like and we were saying like
i i don't know how more people haven't
heard about this even in like the jrpg
community because even like the jrpg
community is a very tight-knit community
whereas if something's good you normally
hear about it from about yeah from like
five different people in the jrpg
community i think the problem is that
because when i tweeted out about it i
thought i was gonna maybe get like three
people being like
you know about it right because again
you don't hear about it but like i think
it just like opened the hatch and like
all the 13 sentinels fans came up be
like yo let's go
because i got so much [ __ ] support
for being like oh he's finally [ __ ]
played the game we've all been trying to
get him to play kind of deal and it's
like
i looked because i was curious i looked
into it being like
why have i not heard of this game until
khan told me that yeah it's because
atlas put literally zero money into the
market
so it they kind of just released it and
was like if you find it here's a gem
yeah but if you don't find it then
you'll never know it existed and i don't
do any marketing
it's because it's because it's literally
impossible to explain the story without
spoiling it yeah actually scratch that
it's literally impossible to explain the
story period
[Laughter]
even if i did spoil it i can't explain
it i was like considering doing a twitch
stream for for this for this playthrough
because i was like i was like more
people need to like experience the story
yeah but then i was like thinking about
what would the experience be like for a
viewer and like if you switch off for
like five minutes you go you go make a
cup of tea or something you're
completely [ __ ] lost again yeah
because you've missed a piece of
information that's important to someone
else's plot somewhere how long is
the game total so
around 30 hours i i think i beat it in
like 30 to 33 hours i'd say that's which
is short for a jrb i was going to say
that's probably
not a bad length yeah for
to stream a game i'd say any game that
takes like over like if you're doing a
full-time shift right let's say eight
hours if it takes more than a week it's
probably too long for twitch i mean i i
tried to stream yakuza seven and that's
a really really long game and yeah a lot
of people fell off like maybe like off
like stream six stream seven yeah yeah
people do like those types of games to
watch especially people who have played
it yeah they [ __ ] love those streams
because they're like i want to see
someone else like experience
insane yeah so that that's cool but also
i mean i don't know it's easier it's
normally easier to stream those kind of
games as well because you're like you're
so invested that like it doesn't feel
like you're live almost yeah i'm just so
into this i think as well but the
problem i because i thought about it so
i was like maybe i should stream it i
don't know but i thought about it and
like i'm glad i didn't because the
reason why i played it back to back
three days in a row is because i thought
to myself if i don't play this game for
more than a day i'm going to forget
everything
but like i remember how it ends but like
it's the build up to how you're getting
to that end which is what makes it so
interesting it's like it's like you have
the beginning and the end and the
beginning is just like this and then
somewhere you go
yeah yeah
and then you're just like i i i we're
here
somehow yeah i don't know how we got
here but we got here we got here and it
was it's a bat [ __ ] say insane journey
but it's like one of the most it is it
is literally vsauce intro of the game
like it's just like you it's like in
this game you follow as this protagonist
or do you
i am tempted to play you guys hyped up
so much i'm like i would have to stream
it i couldn't justify playing a game
that much and not yeah not monetizing it
for me that's god forbid i don't know i
wanna okay the thing is i wanna see you
try and do it
just to see just to see if no no just to
see if your audience can even keep up i
don't i don't even know if i could keep
up bro at the moment is there a skip
option for the cutscenes uh it's all cut
scenes
that's gonna be hard to know i mean
you're basically 100 do they give you
options to skip no okay that's good then
if they don't oh there is a there is a
fast forward option for dialogue you've
already experienced
but like because you experienced the
same
small like i i say this with like zero
irony you need the dialogue you need the
doctor you know i know you do that's the
thing is that it's hard because if i'm
like i'll just get buttons there
let's just say it's not a game i can see
you playing yeah yeah that's why i think
it would be funny to play as well
because i'm just like sure